give me one of the most
loved admired adored presidents of all
time on both sides of the aisle that
they love them
both sides of the aisle it's a very easy
name yeah lincoln obviously okay but
give me one that's in the last hundred
years
jfk jfk sure if i have to say moderate
democrat who would you say
the favorite right wing to the left and
the favorite left wing to the right who
are the two names
jfk and who's the other guy you're
saying the two people that democrats
that were willing to tolerate the
republican and republicans that were
willing to
tolerate the democrat president can
somebody help me out here
one was there jfk's one and who's the
other republican that was loved
reagan okay those two names okay but
let's say jfk
jfk did two things he lowered the taxes
and he told them i'm not lowering the
taxes
just to lower taxes i'm lowering the
taxes so you can capitalize right now
and go make money
to take care of your families what did
jfk say he said don't ask what
your country can do for you but you can
do for your country okay
so then he said we should go land where
on the freaking moon baby do you realize
everything of what jfk say bernie
sanders doesn't stand for
so a democrat who is listening right now
your buddy bernie sanders hates what jfk
stood for
let me say this one more time so jfk
who's a star comes in he says oh
let's go land on the moon this guy's a
freaking nutcase
dude what are you talking about land on
the moon that doesn't matter today we
should land on the moon why
we should go land on them what for
because the 13 year old kid needs to
believe we can land on the moon and he
believes
because the future innovators of america
are just being born today and we need to
inspire them
we should lower taxes why lower taxes
it's not fair
we should raise taxes because we need
help
we need social programs don't ask what
the country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
bernie sanders who cares about going on
the moon and going to you know
a space who cares you should tell about
what the country should do for you we
should raise taxes dude he would hate
jfk today forget about trump
enemy the state number one for bernie is
jfk
so you got to be kidding me so you say
you love america you don't love america
you don't love america you love the
ideas that you would want america to
adopt but that's not america
that's bernie america that's not america
so
adam this is such a critical thing here
because
philosophically when one idea shifts
there are sure there are certain like
you ever heard the thing uh
uh uh in too deep you remember how you
see you know in when you're in too deep
or the tipping point of being in too
deep like for example let's just say you
and i are going
to a club okay we're driving a car and i
say adam let's go we're going to go my
friend a friend's a van
you get in a van okay the guy says hey
guys
let me tell you guys something just
happened right now what's that i got a
100 pounds of kilo
on the back and everybody can you guys
just grab a gun right now
the the guy the cocaine i just got right
now you know i just got it from this guy
it's in the back of the truck dude i'm
like these guys are chasing us i don't
know what the hell to do it's a red
light
okay one guy says dude i'm getting out
you're in the car what are you gonna do
tuck and roll are you gonna get out are
you gonna stay in the car honestly
there's a there's guns there's a hundred
kilos
we're going to miami we're on our way to
spring break we're going to go to miami
yeah
i go into the car with one of my friends
one of my friends brings his friend that
i'm not friends with
this guy all of a sudden i find that
he's got a hundred kilos of cocaine on
her back
yeah i'm not getting an uber i'm good
i'll meet you one guy gets out what are
you doing
there's a red light one guy says dude
i'm out what are you doing
probably leaving with that guy okay but
if you don't get out
and he goes in and the three cars pull
up you're officially in too deep
what's gonna happen there give me the
best case scenario
what's the best case scenario that
happens if the bad guys are chasing you
if the cops chase us what's the best
case scenario
what's the best case not worst case stop
a plea i mean you get arrested you maybe
try to get a lighter sentence
you get free but no matter what you're
in 2d yeah right you had the chance to
get out at the red light but you didn't
very simple we are at the red light
and people can get out and they
better get out because they're gonna get
arrested and
some crimes on your credit will hurt you
for the rest of your life
certain decisions have consequences not
just one year
certain decisions have decades of
consequences and setbacks
america has to be listening up and
realizing
you need to get off the bus right now
sounds juicy sounds exciting sounds
energetic
bernie gets fired up and lit up and
fires everybody up
because he's got more energy and people
like oh my gosh i believe
aoc gets it up she's fired up and people
are like oh she's so persuasive
but i'm telling you right now the rest
of the world
has experienced this it doesn't work get
off the bus
we have to highlight who we want to see
as heroes because we want kids to be
like them
bernie does not love america buddy
not the way you do and you're center or
left
not the way you do not the way i do not
the way anybody loves america bernie
doesn't love that america
yeah i think it's okay to say like me
personally i'm offended by bernie
sanders he's
i find him very offensive with what he
says because what he's saying is wrong
i mean this country has proven that the
way they do it has worked it's why
people sacrifice everything to come here
and i'll tell you the people that are
most offended
by what's going on in this country and
the bernies and these progresses of the
world
that we have right now it's immigrants
it's people that have come to this
country
to start a business to have a chance at
freedom that did it the right way
and they see this i mean they're
offended i have a really good friend
very good friend i was with him on
friday night who's from bologna italy
speaks fluid italian
you'd think you're in italy when you're
with him great businessman he imports
stone
directly from uh italy does a very very
good business in the united states
but he's disgusted by what's going on
here and think about it guys like him
you know they left their whole family
there they came here to start all over
because of what america was it was that
hope it was that dream
that you can do anything here and the
government will stay out of your way
okay that's what america is and now
they're trying to do everything they can
to get in your way and it's offensive
and bernie is wrong
adam you want to plea well look give us
the argument i just want to i just want
to set the record straight i've never
voted for bernie i'm not a bernie bro
i'm not a bernie supporter but i think
it would be wrong to dismiss
everything he ever says and just
unequivocally say he
does not love america and he hates
america because some of the math
i'm not again i'm not supporting bernie
i'm giving the other side
to his argument there's no one here
supporting bernie so someone's got to do
it for this argument you know some of
the numbers he talks about
seven out of 10 workers are living
paycheck to paycheck
billionaires over the pandemic 660
billionaires
their wealth went up over a trillion
dollars the 50
wealthiest americans have more money
than the bottom
half of our society the top like bernie
always says the top one tenth of one to
one percent
have more than the 90 of our entire
country
so ceos are making 320
this is a dan price reference 320
percent more than the average worker
so if i'm an average worker
and i make 45 grand a year and i'm
thinking man
i i can't i got two kids i can't get
ahead
i hear taxes may go up on the super
wealthy making 400 grand i'm making 45
grand
this guy bernie sounds like he knows
what he's talking about
again i'm putting myself in the shoes of
the person making 45 grand a year
nobody is it's an intoxicating argument
is all i'm saying here's here's a
how many parents okay remember the story
i was telling about tico and the kids if
they go to school teacher says something
certain
that that's making 45 grand a year but
but she chose to he chose
nobody told him to be a teacher that's
what you chose what i'm saying to you
have a choice
that's your choice okay you chose to
choose that you get summarized fashion
career
okay and by the way there's benefits to
being a teacher i mean there's a lot of
benefits to being a teacher right you
ain't doing it for money
all good for the record i think teachers
should be paid more that's just my
uh i don't disagree but i also think uh
50 of teachers should be fired and
the other top 20 percent should get a 50
percent rate but i do think
we need to be treated like we get
treated if i don't do the right thing i
get fired and i think teachers should be
fired as well so let me give you we're
going somewhere
i'm going somewhere with this because
you're talking about seven out of ten
people are living paycheck to paycheck
okay
all of these percent the top one percent
owns more than that yeah
okay i all of those things bernie's
argument but that's not an argument
those are statistics correct that's
the thing somebody just said something
right now the guy gave five bucks
and uh bishman said pbd you and bernie
both love america but have different
ways to solve the problems in america to
say someone doesn't love america because
they disagree with bs
i disagree with you bishman because to
me america is just a name
okay to me america is an idea
so if you don't love the ideas of
america you don't love america
that's what it means to me okay because
america to me if they change the idea i
don't like america
i don't this makes sense to you guys or
not it's very simple like you know you
can you can flip if somebody changes
their views and
for example let's just say you
loved your cousin okay you sincerely
love your cousin
and your cousin was a guy with values
and principles your cousin flips
he goes and becomes a drug dealer he
goes and kills a few people and he does
do you you don't you don't stand for the
same thing the values and principles
change i'm sorry i'm not going to sit
there and say
hey go have my kids hang out with you so
let's go back to the 70
of people that are living paycheck to
paycheck yes that is statistic
the question that becomes how we go
about fixing it there's two ways
you have to put the pressure on the
people to take responsibility
or you put the pressure on who the
government or you put the pressure on
rich people
okay in this situation he wants to put
the pressure on who
the rich on the rich people not on the
government not on the people on the rich
people that's not what jfk would have
done and he's a democrat
and the most loved and adored democrat
of all time okay himself
he would have put the pressure and said
hey why don't you do something about it
i was watching an interview yesterday of
the shah with bbc
okay and this is the point where iran's
coming up
they're about to pass up uk okay and
he made a couple predictions that
interview was so powerful i don't know
who shared it with me i'm so glad this
one guy it was 27 minutes
and he said i am begging the word to
users i'm begging
america to stop relying on oil he said
this on 75.
he says i'm begging america to stop
relying on oil the west to stop relying
on oil
but he says one of the problems with uk
is what you know what he says one of the
problems with uk's
he says you guys are too lazy you take
way too many sleeping pills
you guys are too lazy you don't work
that hard he says if your government
got the average worker to work one hour
more a day your economy would change
this i'm not saying five more hours
if they work one more aces if you work
30 minutes more a day
your economy will change rather than a
bernie sanders saying no stay home
it's not fair it's mental issues you're
having
we all have meant i have mentally i've
mentally issues my entire life i have
emotional issues
we all have mental and emotional issues
none of us are robots
but rather than saying that you say hey
johnny question for you what's your
dream
i want to be able to live xyz life great
when you want to have that 10 years why
don't you for the next 10 years
start a side gig make the money save the
money invest the money the right way 10
years from now go live your dream with
your wife and kids
why don't you do that but we're not
talking about that it's we can solve
your problems
anytime the government comes in using
the word help
run who said that not reagan a long time
ago go ahead
okay one last point here is you know
just like bernie sanders
is popular with what he says but just
because he's popular
doesn't mean he's wrong right and he is
wrong and there's evidence that
okay you just take money from the rich
and you hand it out i'll give you a
perfect example if you
a story we've already done today at
vtpost.com
bank of america has done some research
and some polling to find out what people
are spending their stimulus checks on
right the fourteen hundred dollars has
already gone out can you pull it up yeah
it's one of the stories on vtpos.com
right now um you know what they're
finding
people are spending it on shoes and
apparel i mean that is one of the main
things so
there's no direct correlation between
what bernie's saying
and that the country gets better there
is ample evidence of the opposite
and that's why i am so offended by his
message because it doesn't work
and it's it's it's become you know
almost to the point where you're not
allowed to say that because you don't
care
or you don't have feelings for people
that's not true and
i just he's got what does it say it says
the newly somewhat
rich by 1400 combined spending on
parallel athletic footwork jumped 19 and
a half percent year over year for the
week
ending march 12 won a recent comparison
how about the fact that with the same
parameters that spending was up thirteen
point two percent the week prior
stimulus payments began to hit consumer
by the
in the account march 12th or other
avenues for spending including
addressing vision
uh correction concerns and this form of
mojo.com poll responded if i can i'd
also like to pay off my credit card that
it's small and maybe
get on utilities and phone accounts see
people can be responsible the money is
okay
interesting to see this thing taking
place where the money is going to i mean
all they're doing is making nike richer
so phil knight is sitting there saying
send more
stimulus checks out there's also been
some other stories we covered this on
the podcast that
um and millennials are putting money
yeah 40 something percent of millennials
are taking their stimulus checks and
putting in the stock market
some absurd number and then the second
stat hold on hold on
uh in 2009 and 2020 were the only years
that the credit card debt has gone down
in america meaning people have took
their stimulus
and paid off credit cards that's not
because of stimulus that's because
partially it's because of shutdown but
the first point you just made
that's what i agree with okay like you
see what you just did
we're making heroes of the kid that's
taking money investing your thinking
long term
that's not what bernie's doing no but
that's not what bernie's doing
bernie's solution is let me solve it for
you because i can solve it for you
not the entrepreneur and not yourself
you're not good enough
to solve this on your own seventy
percent i don't think you can help
yourself because i'm morality
i'm smarter than you but i'll help you
out don't worry do you know what an
insult it is to think
that you are the one that can solve my
problems and not me
it's an insult that's that's the highest
level of eliteness
versus to say i think you can i think
you can do something about it
i think you can do something about it i
think you think i can do something i
think you can do something about it
we need more politicians saying hey
american people i think you can do
something about it i believe in you here
i have one last thing and
for all both you guys do you think maybe
adam has a different perspective on
things because he's lived in florida and
texas
where you haven't lived in a state where
you really see
an overbearing government and extremely
high taxes and what that does to
day-to-day life
is that a possibility do you think that
maybe i think to flip it when you said
have you partied in miami before you
kind of spooked him i think that's a
very fair assessment to put it on you
you've not lived in other states to kind
of get a feel of what it looks like when
there's over regulation
correct you've lived in a i live in
florida my majority of my heaven on
earth
not saying you're not well traveled
you've been all over them i've been all
over all over the world
my favorite city is new york city by the
way i i would say that as well
i i don't i don't dispute that so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you